The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT
courses, visit MIT
OpenCourseWare at ocw.mit.edu,
ERIK DEMAINE: Today we continue
our theme of dynamic graphs.
This is the second
of three lectures.
And this will be the main
lecture about upper bounds
for general graphs.
Last class was about
link cut trees.
And we saw, essentially,
how to solve
a problem called dynamic
connectivity, which
is where you can
insert into lead edges
and you want to know
what's connected to what.
For trees, we solved it.
We're going to solve it again
for trees in an easier way.
Because we need a slightly
simpler data structure
we can augment in different
ways, called Euler-tour trees.
And then we'll solve
trees, yet again,
in a setting where you
can only delete edges.
Then we can get from log
n time to constant time.
So we'll still talk about
trees for quite awhile.
But then we'll finally
get to general graphs.
And we'll do a log squared n
solution for general graphs.
So just another log
factor more, you
can generalize from trees
to undirected graphs.
And then I'll give you a
flavor of what's out there.
Dynamic graphs is a big world.
It has lots of results.
And I'll give you some idea
of what other problems have
been studied in dynamic graphs,
both undirected and directed.
Though for directed graphs,
things get pretty slow.
Yeah, next class will be
about lower bounds, which
will prove that this log
stuff is actually necessary,
in case you were wondering.
Because a lot of
the time, we've been
able to get better
than log in this class.
And dynamic graphs, you can't.
They're log lower bounds.
So let's start out with a
definition of the problem.
We'll be focusing, today, mostly
on this dynamic connectivity
problem.
Maintain an undirected
graph subject to [INAUDIBLE]
insertion and deletion.
And you can also insert and
delete degree-0 vertices.
But we're not really going
to worry about vertices.
It's easy to add vertices
that have no edges to them.
Also easy to delete them.
It'll be more about adding
and removing edges incident
to those vertices.
And then the query connectivity
query is given two vertices.
Is there a v to w path?
So this is asking are
two vertices, v and w,
in the same connected component?
That's a strong query.
In some sense, a weaker query
is just to know globally,
is the graph connected?
That's another interpretation
of dynamic connectivity.
It turns out, both
of these problems
are interesting and useful
for solving problems.
But they also turn out to
be, more or less, equivalent.
All the upper bounds
we know for one
apply to the other
and vice versa.
So it doesn't seem to make much
difference which kind of query
you want.
So might as well take both.
We'll focus on the v, w query.
OK.
So that's the
problem, in general.
And I want to introduce
some terminology,
like when we had partially
and full persistence,
there's also a partial
and full dynamicness.
A fully dynamic
data structure is
one where you can do inserts
and deletes of edges.
And a partially
dynamic data structure
is one where you can
do inserts or deletes.
So you can only do
inserts, or you can only
do deletes throughout the
lifetime of the data structure.
And these have specific names.
Because usually you use
different data structures
for just insertions
or just deletions.
Just insertions is
called incremental.
And just deletions is
called decremental.
The idea of
incremental algorithms
is definitely not a new one.
But in dynamic graphs,
it always makes sense.
So in general, a
dynamic graph problem
is defined usually by insertion
and deletion of edges,
and either fully dynamic
or partially dynamic.
And then the query
is what can vary.
We're going to focus on
connectivity queries.
But you could do others.
So this explains, for
decremental, we're
going to solve trees
in constant time.
For fully dynamic, we're
going to solve general graphs
in log squared n time.
I guess these three are sort
of the meat of the lecture.
But before I go
into that, I want
to tell you where this dynamic
connectivity results fit
into the literature in general
on dynamic connectivity.
This is part of our survey, but
just on dynamic connectivity.
Well, for trees, this
is the best we know.
This is the best,
possible really.
You can do log n in general,
and then decremental.
You can do constant.
We actually already know how to
do trees with lint cut trees.
It's not totally obvious,
but you can use links
to simulate edge insertions.
And you can use cuts to
simulate edge deletions.
It's not totally obvious
because the link operation
requires that one
of the vertices
is the root of its tree.
So that's not so trivial.
But we'll see an easy way to
do that in Euler-tour trees
later on.
So this we kind of
already know how to do.
But we're going to see
another simpler way.
The constant time
amortized decremental
we're going to do today.
So we're also going
to do this today.
Incremental, I don't think it's
known, how to do constant time.
But I'll tell you
another result.
You can get almost
constant time.
Another special type of
graph you could consider
is a plane graph.
This is a graph with
planar embedding.
So as you're inserting edges
or adding vertices and whatnot,
you say which face they live in.
And so you have a
fixed planar embedding.
It's being constructed
as you go along.
These are easy to maintain.
You can get order log n.
I guess, in some sense,
that generalizes trees.
Because they also have pretty
obvious planar embedding.
So that's something
you can do, in log n.
But the big question
is, for general graphs,
can you do log n per operation?
That's an open problem, probably
the central open problem
in dynamic connectivity.
But we're not so
far away from that.
As I said, you can
get log squared.
Let me say what the
log squared result is.
It's a little bit better
than just log squared.
You get log squared
update, but query
is actually sub logarithmic.
You got a log n over
log log n query.
And another result is
you can do a little bit
better than log squared.
You can do log times
log log n cube update.
So roughly log n update, but
there's some poly log log term.
And query slows
down very slightly.
It becomes log n
over a log log log n.
Well, it'll sort of makes
sense why in a moment.
So the lowest update time known
is this one, log times log
log cubed.
Big open question is whether
you can get log for update,
and any kind of
reasonable query time.
But ideally, log for both.
So that's for a fully dynamic.
If I don't say any
otherwise, fully dynamic
is always the default.
Result, that's
the case you usually care about.
Cool.
But if you want
to do incremental,
you can achieve an alpha bound.
Because incremental dynamic
connectivity is really
the union find problem.
Union find, you have a
bunch of sets of elements.
You can take two of them
and union them together.
Once they're unioned, they
can never be split apart.
And find is tell
me what set I'm in.
So if I do find
on two vertices, I
can find which connected
components there
and check whether
they're the same.
That will give me
connectivity query.
Insertion corresponds to
merging two connected components
unless they were
already together.
And it's known you can get
an alpha amortized bound.
And that's optimal
for that problem.
So I guess that's
actually a theta.
So that's sort of
well-known stuff.
It's a complicated analysis,
but already been done.
So in particular, that's,
I believe, the best way
we know how to solve incremental
connectivity in trees.
Though I'm curious whether you
can do constant incremental.
Decremental, there's
essentially a log n solution.
Not quite, but for dense graphs,
there's a log n solution.
So I'm stating, instead
of a bound per operation,
this is a total bound.
Let's say you start
with an m-edge graph
and you delete all the edges.
Then you pay log
n for each edge.
But you also have to pay
this n poly log n cost.
So if m is a bit bigger
than n, then this dominates.
And so it's log n per operation.
But if you have a
sparse graph, it's
still poly log per operation.
So decremental, we can kind
of get log for general graphs.
Another goal you might
have is what if I wanted
to get worse-case bounds?
Everything I've said
so far is amortized.
If you want to get worse
case, not much is known.
Big open question is, can I
get a poly log updating query.
So it was actually a pretty big
breakthrough to get poly log
whatsoever.
This first result
is from 2001 or so,
after people have worked on
dynamic graphs for probably
a decade.
So it took quite a while to
find this any kind of poly log.
That still hasn't
been made worse case.
So the best results
are state of the art
at the time, before
the poly log came out,
which is square root of
n update, constant query.
There's one other result
for worse case, which
is if you want to do an
incremental solution,
so you're just inserting edges.
Then there's a bound.
It's actually a whole trade off
between updates and queries.
If you have updates
to take order x time,
then you get queries that
take log n over log x time.
So log base x of n.
And that's optimal.
These are theta.
There's matching lower bounds.
So this is again,
really union find.
And so union find has
been well studied,
even in the worse-case setting.
Can't do as well as
alpha, basically.
OK.
And then finally, I want
to talk about lower bounds.
So there are two
complementary results.
But maybe first I'll
summarize by saying you need
omega log n update or query.
One of them has to
be at least log n
to do dynamic connectivity.
As you see, queries
can be sublogarithmic.
We don't know how to make
updates sublogarithmic
and get any
reasonable query time.
But one of them has
to be at least log.
And here's the specific
theorems that imply that.
That's actually similar to this
result, but not quite the same.
Because there's a log
on the left-hand side.
And these results hold
for amortized solutions.
Whoops.
Key word's missing here.
This is an update bound.
And this is a query bound.
So these are basically
symmetric results.
Says if you have super
logarithmic update,
so you have some x bigger
than 1 times log n update,
then you get log n
over log x query.
That's a lower bound.
If you have a super
logarithmic query,
so let's say it's x
times larger than log n,
then you need at least a log
n over log x update time.
So this result is
the one of relevance.
Because we don't know any
sublogarithmic updates.
But we do know
sublogarithmic queries.
So this is the
regime that we have,
essentially, matching
upper bounds.
Let me show you.
This result, this
result, and this result,
even, are, in some sense,
tight against this trade-off,
this update query trade-off.
So this update is
log n times log n.
So x is log n.
And over here we get
log n over log log n.
So that's tight against that.
Here, also, we have here
x is log log n cubed.
So you take a log of log log n
cubed, you get log log log n.
So that's why there's a
log log log n down here.
That's the best
you could hope for,
given that update time,
that's the best query
time you can get.
Same over here.
Given an update time of root
n, well, of course, the best
you can hope for
is constant query.
But indeed, it works out.
As you're taking log n
divided it by 1/2 log n,
you get constant.
So these results, they
may sound suboptimal.
But a certain sense,
they're optimal.
Of course, these are just single
points on the trade-off curve.
We still really care
about the situation of--
where's the open
problem here-- log n
update and query, that
would still be ideal.
But these are not as bad
as they look, is the point.
Of course, it'd be better
if this wasn't a 3,
it was only a 1.
But they're still,
in a certain sense,
tight against this, the
query bound that you get.
Another open problem
here is whether this,
the reverse situation,
is ever relevant.
Can you have a
sublogarithmic update time
and get any poly log query time?
So this is another open problem.
Little o of log n query.
Sorry, little o of log n update,
and let's say poly log query.
The lower bound kind of predicts
that something like this
ought to exist.
But it may be it's
just impossible.
And there's a different lower
bound that makes it impossible.
Some theta I wanted to add here.
OK.
Another fun thing
about this lower bound,
is that it holds even if
your graphs are paths.
So in particular, that tells us
that this dynamic tree result
that we covered last
class, say, you need log n.
If you're going to do
both operations and log n,
that's optimal.
Even if your trees
are paths, which
is like the really easy case.
And we're going to prove
this theorem next class.
So if you want, that'll
be our last class,
our last lower bound.
That's next time.
Tune in next time.
But today we're going to
focus on upper bounds, namely
these two and this one.
So let's do them.
The first one is
Euler-tour trees,
which is another way
to do the log n bound.
It's something we need.
We'll need it for doing
the log squared solution,
for a reason we'll
see in a moment.
So Euler-tour tress go back
to 1995, Henzinger and King.
They're simpler dynamic
trees, simpler than link cut,
even though they're newer.
And the key difference
compared to link cut trees
is that they let you
do stuff with subtrees
of the tree instead
of paths of the tree.
Link cut trees are great.
We could compute
the min or the max
or the sum of a bunch
of weights on any path
that we cared about.
But for various reasons, we
want to do the same thing
on subtrees.
And this turns out to be easier.
So what do we do with
Euler-tour trees?
We take an Euler-tour.
Remember Euler-tour from-- I
can never remember-- lecture 15.
[LAUGHS]
I don't quite remember
what that lecture was.
When did we do Euler-tours?
Well, doesn't matter.
You remember the idea
of an Euler-tour.
It was just walk around the
tree, do a depth for search,
and keep track of every
time you visit a node.
So you visit some
nodes multiple times.
In general, the
degree of the node
is the number of
times you visit it.
Every edge gets
visited exactly twice.
So it's the linear
number of visits total.
I just want to take that
linear order of visits,
pull it out straight, store
that in a balanced binary search
tree.
That's Euler-tour trees.
They're very simple.
Store the node visits
by the Euler-tour,
and a balanced
binary search tree.
What's the order?
We're storing them
in order by the order
that the Euler-tour
visits, the visits.
So this will be the left-most,
the min in the tree.
This will be the
next and then next.
So if you do an in-order
traversal of the tree,
you should get the
visits in this order.
This is, of course, a way to
balance a tree, in some sense.
I drew a balanced
tree as the thing
we're trying to represent.
But again, it could be a
totally unbalanced thing.
But when you do an Euler-tour,
you get order n visits.
And you throw them into
a balanced binary search
tree, it's balanced, of course.
It's a bit of a weird thing,
because you're not really
preserving the structure
in an obvious way.
But there's one
more thing we store,
which will let us do,
essentially, whatever we want.
Each node stores two
pointers into this structure
to the first and last visit.
So like this node has a
pointer to its first visit
and its last visit
along this structure.
It doesn't keep track
of any middle visits.
Because there could
be a lot of those.
And we just want to have a
constant number of pointers.
This is going to be a pointer
machine data structure
just like link cut trees.
Let's see.
How do we solve our operations,
inserting and deleting
of edges and connectivity?
Actually, I'll start
with just phrasing it
like link cut trees.
We can do most of the
link cut tree operations.
Remember, there was a
find root, link and cut
were our main operations.
Than there was aggregation.
But that will have to change.
But if we want to do find root--
so we're given one of these
balanced binary search trees.
In it is the node v.
Well, actually, it's
a little weirder here.
But we have some
node v in our tree.
And really, we have
our pointers into this.
This is a balanced
binary search tree here.
We have pointers to the
first and last visit in here.
I don't care.
Just take any visit,
anything in here,
just say the first visit of
v. Then walk up the tree.
Then walk down the
tree on the left spine.
That is the min.
And that's going to be the
first visit of the root node.
And so this has a pointer,
in turn, to the root node.
Boom, you found the
root of your tree.
Again, we're maintaining
forest of trees.
And so we just need to
find which tree v is in,
walk up, walk down,
that's order log
n, because this
thing is balanced,
and we found the root.
So that's easy.
Turns out, the other
operations are not too easy
if you can split and
concatenate your tree.
So let's start with cut.
We need a bigger diagram.
So here's v. Here's the
parent of v. I'll call it w.
Here's the edge.
And our goal, and
the cut operation
is to delete that edge, separate
this tree from that tree.
So what I need to do is
isolate this subtree of v.
But conveniently, if you
think of the Euler-tour,
the Euler-tour, it
does some stuff here.
Eventually it follows this edge.
Visits v for the
first time here.
Then it visits all
the stuff down here.
Then it visits v
for the last time.
Then it follows this edge
and then does other stuff.
So the v subtree is a contiguous
interval of the Euler-tour.
So we just cut it
open, cut it apart.
So we split the BST at
the first and last visits
to v, which is
exactly what we know.
We have a pointer from v to
its first and last visits
in the Euler-tour.
So split the tree there.
Split the tree there.
You know split in a
binary search tree.
You're given a particular
key value, let's say, x.
And you split into
everything less than x,
and everything great than
or equal to x, or something
like that.
That's a split operation.
It can be done in
log n time, and pick
your favorite balanced
binary search tree.
Red-black trees, AVL
trees, they can all
do this and maintain
balance in these two things.
Even though they might
be very different sizes,
they'll both be log height
relative to their own size.
This is obviously
not quite enough.
Because what we've
done is basically
cut here and cut here.
Now we have three trees.
We have the one we want
for v, v is subtree.
That will correspond
to the Euler-tour
of exactly that thing.
So this is the represented
tree I'm talking about.
And this is the balanced
binary search tree.
But the rest of the
tree is in two parts.
There's the part
to the left of v,
before we visited v, the
part after we visited
v. Those we just have
to stick back together,
so we concatenate them.
Yeah.
So I'll call them the before-v
tree and the after-v tree.
There is actually a tiny
thing that has to happen here,
which I just remembered.
Which is we need, somewhere,
to delete one occurrence of w,
of the parent of v.
Because it used to be we
visit w, then we visit v,
blah, blah, blah.
Then we visit w again.
If we cut out this
part, we're going
to have two visits
to w in a row.
We really just want one visit.
So this is a minor thing, but
we need to do a delete in there.
So each of these is log n time.
So the overall time is log n.
Easy.
This is a cut-and-paste kind
of argument, all pretty cheap.
OK, now let's do link.
Concatenate is the reverse
of split, by the way.
You have two trees.
All the things in
the left are smaller
than all things in the right.
You just want to
join them together
like a very restrictive
kind of merge.
So join, recall, is you have a
node v. And you want to make it
a new child of w.
w might have other children.
It lives in some bigger tree.
We want to add v
as a child of w.
So we're assuming here
v is a root, for now.
So what do we do?
Sort of the same thing.
We sort of know we want to
put v in here somewhere.
It actually doesn't really
matter where we put it.
We're not keeping track of
the order of nodes in here.
So I'm going to simplify
my life and say,
let's put v at the end.
I want to make v the last
child of w, like this.
So we can find the last
child, in some sense.
After we visit the last
child, we come back
and do the last visit to w.
So I'm going to look
at the last visit of w,
cut the tree open there,
and stick this part in.
Cut the Euler-tour
in half there.
So split.
w is tree at w's last visit.
Right?
And then we do
omega concatenate.
We're going to
concatenate, basically,
before w's last visit.
We're going to concatenate
a single occurrence of w.
Because there's a new
occurrence of w now.
We do it before and after v.
So we add another w.
Then we add v's
Euler-tour, v's BST,
and then we do after
whatever used to be there
after w's last visit.
Let's say, after and
including that w visit.
So just the symmetric
of this, here
we had to delete
one occurrence of w.
Here we have to add one back in.
But you just cut, paste
in the thing you need,
and rejoin everything.
So again, very easy.
It's a constant number
of log n time operations,
if you can do split and
concatenate in log n time.
So you see this, it's like wow,
why do we spend so much time
with link cut trees?
This is really easy.
But they have their
different applications.
If you want to compute
aggregates on paths
you need to use link cut tress.
It's the best we know.
This structure will not
do aggregates on paths.
But it will do
aggregates on subtrees.
Because subtrees are
represented by these intervals
in the Euler-tour tree.
So if you have a weight
on all the nodes in here,
say, you can easily
find this interval
and do a range query there.
So you take the min
of all those things.
If you have subtree
mins, you can
take the min of log n
things and in log n time,
compute the min in an
interval, or min over
a subtree rooted at a node,
or max or sum, or whatever.
So here you can do subtree
aggregation in log n time.
And we're going to need that
for the log squared solution.
One other thing I
wanted to maybe mention,
here we did join.
And join assumed that v
was the root of its tree.
What if v is not
the root of its tree
and we still want
to insert an edge?
Because insert, when
we're maintaining
an undirected graph,
there is no rootedness.
That rootedness is just a tool.
You could say at the first
step here, just root the tree
somewhere so that we can
have a well-defined beginning
and end to the Euler-tour.
Of course, Euler-tour in
it's the most natural form,
is actually a cycle.
And it would only
have one visit here.
So you can think of it that way.
I'd still like to have the
two visits conceptually,
because that makes even the
subtree rooted at the root
an interval between the
beginning and the end.
But the nice thing
of the cycle view
is if I wanted to
change who the root is,
say I want this node to
be the root, that's just
a cyclic shift of everything.
It just means I want to start
the cycle here and end it here.
So I'd basically duplicate this
copy of the vertex, singlify
this one.
There's only one copy.
That's the constant number
of inserts and deletes.
And now rotate.
[LAUGHS]
What does it rotate mean?
Well, before it was
a sequential order,
starting here, ending here.
Now, I want it to be a
sequential order, say,
starting here, continuing this
way, and then ending back here.
So if you look at what
that requires, maybe
use another color,
I want this part.
That's an interval of the old
tree, of the old sequence.
And then I want this part.
So there's two pieces
of the old tree.
And I just want to
change their order.
It's a cyclic shift.
Cyclic shift is just a cut and
then a rejoin the other way.
So I can reroute a tree
in log n time as well.
So this is why, in this world,
join is equivalent to insert.
If I want to do
a general insert,
first I reroute v's tree.
I do a cyclic shift with
one split one concatenate,
like this.
And I get v to be the root.
Then I can do the join.
So again, constant number
of splits and concatenates.
So it's another operation
we can do, in log in.
Everything here is log n.
Cool.
Any questions about
Euler-tour trees.
That's all I'll say about them.
We will next move
on to next result.
AUDIENCE: Can link cut
trees also do a reroute?
ERIK DEMAINE: Can link cut
tress also do a reroute?
I haven't thought about that.
I would guess so.
[LAUGHS]
But it's going to require
some more thought.
So let's see, link cut tree,
we can do a little aside here.
Link cut tree, we
do an axis on v.
So now we get that v is
up here, right at the root
of the tree of oxx trees.
Now we've got other trees of
[INAUDIBLE] trees hanging off
here.
But in particular, this
thing represents a path.
It represents the
route to v path.
It actually has no right child.
So it's a little bit
emptier, like that.
So now we want to flip things
around and say v is the root.
We basically want
to reverse the order
of all the nodes in this tree.
So reversing the order of
nodes in a binary search tree,
you can't regularly do.
But if you augment your
data structure to say,
I could basically mark
these nodes as all inverted,
treat left as right
and right as left.
It's basically the
dyslexic approach.
You have a bit
saying from here down
to here, mark
everything as dyslexic.
And so you invert
left and right.
So I think, with this
appropriate augmentation,
you can reroute the
tree in log n time.
But of course, there's
some details to check.
It might even be that's in the
original link cut tree paper.
But I don't remember offhand.
So I'm pretty sure it
works, and therefore,
gives you dynamic connectivity.
But if it doesn't,
Euler-tour trees do it too.
So we're covered either way.
So that's Euler-tour trees.
Next on our list is decremental
connectivity in trees.
So we're going to solve
a weaker problem, which
is just deletions only instead
of inserts and deletes.
We're going to solve it faster.
Constant time per operation.
This is just a
fun little result.
It's fun because it uses
some techniques we know.
So bound is constant amortized,
assuming all edges get deleted.
We need to assume
this, essentially,
because we're amortizing
against the future.
So we need to get all
the way to the end.
Overall, over n operations it's
going to take order n time.
This is, again, a
series of refinements,
or a bunch of pieces of
the solution that get
combined together, not
a sequential algorithm.
So the first observation is, of
course, we can do order log n.
We know, now, maybe
two ways to do it.
But you can use Euler-tour trees
and only do cuts, life is easy.
Link cut trees, you
could also just do cuts.
You don't even need rerouting.
Rerouting was only for joins.
So that may seem obvious.
But how do we reduce
the log n to a constant?
In general, in this class?
AUDIENCE: Make up tables.
ERIK DEMAINE: Indirection,
and maybe look up tables.
Yep.
How do we do
indirection in a tree?
AUDIENCE: Leaf pruning?
ERIK DEMAINE: Leaf
pruning, leaf trimming,
whatever you want to call it.
Should call it the Edward
Scissorhands approach,
or something.
So leaf trimming,
what I want to do
is cut below
maximally deep nodes
that are [INAUDIBLE] log n.
Say with greater than
log n descendants.
So we have our top tree.
And then hanging
off some nodes here,
we're going to have
some bottom trees.
These each have, at
most, log n nodes.
These have bigger than
log n nodes below them.
So we can charge every
leaf in the structure
to the log n nodes below it.
And so up here we have at most,
sorry, n over log n leaves.
Not nodes.
Nodes could still be linear
if the graph is a path.
But at most, n
over log n leaves.
So we have, at most, n over
log n branching nodes up here.
So what we need is a
structure for dealing
with long paths in
the top, a structure
for dealing with log n
size things down here,
and a structure for
combining the paths together.
And that's the easy part.
If we treat each long
path as a single edge,
basically, we look at
the compressed top tree,
in the sense of
compressed tries.
But it's now a tree
instead of a try.
I guess it's a try.
Whatever
We look at the
compressed tree up here.
That will have
size, n over log n.
And then we can afford
to use structure one.
Why?
Because in some
sense, there only
be n over log n
operations performed.
So it's not a space issue
there we're trying to save.
It's a time issue.
So a little different
from the past.
There are only n
over log n times
that you can destroy
a path up here.
Because there's only
n over log n paths.
Each time you destroy a path,
I do an operation up here,
I pay log n.
But if the total number of
operations n over log n,
total cost is linear.
So constant amortized
against the future.
So I'm going to use structure
one on the compressed top tree.
And what remains is what
I do in the bottom trees?
What I do on the paths?
And then how do I combine
all those results together?
Let's first talk about how
to combine the results.
There are a couple
of different cases.
It So we're doing
a query on v, w,
and we want to do
connectivity query.
So it could be that v and w
are in the same bottom tree.
In that case, we just need to
do a query within a bottom tree.
So as long as we can solve
the bottom tree case quickly,
we're happy.
Constant time, I guess.
That will turn out
to be pretty easy.
That's the easy case.
Otherwise they could be
in different bottom trees.
So it could be v's down here and
w's in some other bottom tree.
So then we have three
queries we need to do.
One is like this.
We need to test the single
edge, but that's trivial.
And then we need to
do a query in the top.
Can you get from here to here?
Now, these nodes are
a little bit special,
because they are leaves.
They will be at
the ends of paths.
So this is really just a query
we can do using structure one.
Because we take either an
entire path or no path at all.
So we can look at
the compressed tree
and that's enough,
because the leaves
exist on the compressed tree.
That's not always the case.
A different situation is this.
We might have, for example,
v up here, w up here,
and v and w are not down here.
So these are irrelevant.
We just want to know, in the
top tree, can I get from v to w?
Now, this is a
little more awkward
because v is going
to live on some path.
w is going to live on some path.
But it might be in
the middle of a path.
And so there's now three
queries we need to do.
One is can I get to
the top of my path?
And then can I get from
one path to the other?
So these are
branching nodes here.
And can I get from
this branching node
to that branching node?
It might not always be going up.
Sometimes you have to go down.
But point is, a constant number
of queries to path structures,
to compressed structures.
This is, again,
the one structure.
And a constant number of
calls to a bottom structure
will suffice to
answer the query.
There's a few more cases
that I haven't drawn.
If you could be half of
this and half of this.
But it can all be
done, as long as we
can solve bottom and paths.
So let's solve paths
first, I think.
Oh no, bottom trees, fine.
So part 3 of the solution
is solve a bottom tree.
Here we can do it in
constant worse case.
So this is essentially
the lookup table thing,
although it's a pretty
simple lookup table.
What we do, bottom tree
has only log n nodes.
So we can represent 1 bit
per node in a single word.
And what we'll do, store
bit vector of which
edges have been deleted.
In what order?
I don't really care.
Just pick some fixed order
on the edges down here,
and store the bits
in that order.
And say every edge
knows its sequence.
So you could do a depth first
search at the beginning,
to label the edges in
some canonical order.
And then every edge knows
what its bit position
is in the vector.
So when I go to
delete an edge, I just
set that one bit
using an or operation.
Cool.
So I can delete edges.
I can actually even insert edges
down here that used to exist.
I could undelete an edge.
But that only works in
the bottom structure.
So not generally useful.
OK, so it's clear how to do
an update, how to do a delete.
I just mark a bit.
How do I do a query?
I want to know, given two
nodes, v and w, one of them
could be the root of the tree.
I want to know can
I get from v to w?
Or there's only a single
path that might exist.
So it's a matter of has any edge
along this path been deleted?
So a general way to
write that is I have w.
I look at v's path to the root.
I look at w's path to the root.
At some point,
we've reach the LCA.
What I want to know is, have
any of these edges been deleted?
If yes, I can't get there.
If none of them have been
deleted, I can get there.
It's an if and only if.
I don't care about these
edges up here above the LCA.
Because I only need to go
to the LCA and back down.
So what do I do?
Each vertex stores a bit
vector of its ancestors,
of the ancestor edges.
Well, ancestor edges
is kind of weird.
It stores a bit vector
representing its path
to the root.
That's this red stuff.
I want to know,
for vertex v, what
are the edges along the path to
the root of this bottom tree?
Just preprocessed.
You can build this thing as
you do the depth first search
and store it.
Again, it's one word per vertex.
So I can fit it
with constant space.
It's constant space overhead.
And now, if I have
two vertices, I
take the XOR of those two paths.
That will give me this part.
And then I use that as a mask
into the bit vector, say,
are any of these 1?
How do I do that?
I just mask.
And if the result is the 0 word,
then I know none of them are 1.
Otherwise, I know some edge
was deleted and I'm screwed.
So I take XOR of v's
path and w's path.
And then I mask this thing,
which stores which edges
were deleted.
And then I check whether
that word equals 0.
If it equals 0, yes,
I can get there.
If it doesn't equal
0, I can't get there
because some edge was deleted.
So very easy, because we can
fit log n bits in a word.
OK, that's the bottom
tree structure.
Next we need a path structure.
Here we can use due constant
amortized with a similar trick.
So here's our path.
We're going to use,
essentially, indirection again.
Again, we know how to
solve this in log n.
When we have a sequential thing,
our usual way of indirection
is to split into chunks.
Each chunk here, I need
to be about log n in size.
So I'll just make it
exactly log n in size.
So there's n over log n chunks.
So if I store a
summary vector, we
can think of these
as being 0, 1, 0, 1,
whatever, where the 1's mean
this edge has been deleted.
0 means it hasn't been deleted.
All right, let me write n over
log n chunks, each log n edges.
And I'm going to store
each chunk as a bit vector.
Bit vector has log n bits.
w's at least log n.
So I can do the same sort
of things I could do before.
If I delete an edge, I just set
a 1 bit in the chunk vector.
Now, that's good
for local queries.
If I want to do a
long-distance query,
I need to basically summarize,
are any of these edges deleted?
If so, I'll put a 1 up here.
Any of these edges deleted?
If not, put a 0.
And now, I want to
structure over-- this,
you might call the summary
vector, like in [INAUDIBLE]..
Done that before with
indirection as well.
Now, this summary vector
has size n over log n.
So I can afford to use our log
n solution that we started with.
So use 1 on summary
vector of chunks.
Because again, the first time
I set one of the bits in here,
I have to do an update up here.
But only then.
Once it's been done once, I
don't have to update again.
So there will only be
n over log n updates.
So I can afford
log n per update.
It'll still be linear time
total, constant per operation
amortized.
So this is my solution.
If I have a query, let's say
I want to know between here
and here, I first check, can
I get to the right endpoint
locally?
Which is a query
within the chunk.
Which is again, I just
mask out these bits.
I say and now do I
have the 0 vector?
In which case, nothing I
care about has been deleted
and I can get there?
Or if I don't have the 0
vector, I can't get there.
I want to know, can I get
to the left from here?
Again it's a mask and
a check against 0.
And then I want to
know, can I go over
this interval of chunks?
And that, I can use
the summary vector for.
And again, that is a
mask of a subinterval,
and then checking
whether it has 0.
So I take the and of these
three results, and I'm done.
That gives me a
query over a path.
So it's kind of fun.
We use two levels
of indirection.
One to reduce the
number of leaves.
And then these were
sort of trivial.
And then within the structure,
we could only afford things
on the non-branching
part, so we had
to deal with paths separately.
And there we use another
level of indirection.
But in the end, we get
rid of all of our logs.
And it's constant amortized
for deletions in a tree.
Questions about that?
That was our second
result. We have one more.
Last result we're
going to talk about
is log squared n
update, log over log log
query, for general graphs.
Finally, we graduate from
trees to general graphs.
This is a result by Holm,
de Lichtenberg, and Thorup,
2001 is the journal version.
So we want to solve
dynamic connectivity.
We want to understand,
in general,
when two vertices are in
the same connected component
or not.
That sounds tricky.
We're going to do that
in a pretty simple way
at a high level.
High level is, we want to
store a spanning forest.
You know what a
spanning tree is.
Spanning forest, well, your
graph might be disconnected.
That's the whole point
of the data structure.
If it's not disconnected,
you answer yes all the time.
When it's disconnected
you say, OK, I'll
have a spanning tree for
this connected component,
spanning tree for every
connected component.
Together we call that
a spanning forest.
That's the maximal connectivity
you can get, but represented
as a tree.
Now, we have a great
way to represent
trees, Euler-tour trees.
And if you somehow connected
together two components,
that is an insertion of an edge
in an Euler-tour structure.
Great.
So we can maintain all
these connected components
and merge them if we
have to, using an insert
in Euler-tour structure.
And to do a connectivity query--
I don't think I mentioned this--
you do find root on v and w,
see whether they're
the same root.
Because root is a canonical name
for the connected component.
You can solve connectivity using
find root in constant time.
Well, constant extra time,
log for the find root.
OK, so everything looks great.
I can connectivity.
I can do insertion.
What about deletion?
If I delete an edge that is
not in my spanning forest,
I'm happy.
I have exactly the same
connectivity as before,
as proved by the
spanning forest.
The trouble is when I
delete an edge that's
in the spanning forest.
Then it's like, uh, maybe.
So here's spanning
tree, whatever.
And now let's say I
delete this edge here.
Then there's a
couple possibilities.
It was a graph, it's not a tree.
So there could be
some other edge
that connects those two trees.
Then I have to find it.
Oh, I'm going to find it.
That's going to be annoying.
Or it could be
there's no such edge.
Then I'm fine.
Then it's just a cut.
But distinguishing
those two cases
is going to be our challenge.
And that's where we're going
to lose another log factor,
but only another log factor.
To only lose another log
factor, what we're going to do
is not just store
one spanning forest.
We will store the
spanning forest,
but then we're going to
hierarchically decompose it
and say, well, yeah,
there's this big tree.
But some of the edges I'm going
to put in the next level down.
Some I won't.
So some subset of this forest
will be at the next level down.
And there's going
to be log n levels.
That's where we
lose our log factor.
And the weird thing is,
there's no real reason
to put things down, except we'll
use it as a charging scheme.
We'll prove that an edge can
only go down log n levels.
And then it has to get deleted
before it becomes relevant
again.
So it will let us charge
only log n times per edge.
OK, that's about as
good as I can give you
a high-level overview.
Now we have to see the details.
It's kind of amazing that
this works, but it does.
So we're going to talk
about the level of an edge.
This is not a
definition, per se.
But it's a change in
quantity over time.
As you do edge
deletions, some edges
are going to decrease in level.
They all start at log n.
Log n is going to
be the top level.
That's the whole
spanning forest.
They will only decrease,
so it's monotone.
And they can never get below 0.
So we start at log n.
They could go down.
And the lowest value is 0.
Now, Gi is my graph.
And G is going to be the
subgraph of lower-level edges.
It's going to say, level
less than or equal to i.
So in particular, G log
n is the whole graph.
So we always include
lower-level edges.
So level 0 is going to
appear in all the Gi's.
But if we look at G 0,
it's only level 0 edges.
G1 is level 0 and 1.
And so this is sort of a
hierarchical decomposition
of the graph.
We have fewer edges
at the bottom levels.
And there's going to
be two key invariants
we have over these structures.
In variant one it's is going
to be every connected component
of Gi is small.
It's going to be size,
at most, 2 to the i.
This is really
what's going to let
us charge against something.
Whenever you go down
a level, the max size
of a connected component
goes down by a factor of 2.
So at level 0, all
components have size 1.
There are no edges at level 0.
So I kind of lied.
I guess the lowest level is 1.
At level 1, you can
have two vertices.
So there can be
isolated edges in Gi.
But that's it.
You can't have a path of length
2 in G1, and so on up the tree.
At G log n, you can
have the whole graph.
Whole thing could be connected.
But this will let us
charge to something
as we go down in the tree.
As we go down in
levels, I should say.
So next thing we need is a
spanning forest for each Gi.
Fi is going to be
spanning forest of Gi.
So it's going to maintain the
connected components of Gi.
And we're going to store that
using an Euler-tour tree.
There's this issue
of pluralization.
I'll say trees.
Because Fi is disconnected.
Each connected
component you use,
you store using an
Euler-tour tree.
Together, it's an Euler-tour
forest, I suppose.
So that way we can do a query.
And so given two
nodes, we can know
whether they're in the same
connected component in Fi,
just by saying whether they
live under the same root.
Well, in particular,
that means that f
log n, which is a
spanning forest of G log
n, which is everything, that
will let me solve queries.
This is the desired
spanning forest
that will let me ask
connectivity queries.
So all this
infrastructure is in order
to support deletes efficiently.
But queries are easy.
We just look at the top forest.
That's the one we want.
OK, now second
invariant, this is
where things get interesting.
Variant 2.
The forests have to nest.
So F log n, of course,
has the most edges.
F0 is going to have
the fewest edges.
But I want them to be contained
in this nested structure.
All this is saying is
that there's really only
one spanning forest, F log n.
Fi is just F log n, but
restricted to the edges of Gi.
So really we're trying
to represent this forest.
But then, as we look
at lower levels,
we just forget about
the higher-level edges.
Restrict to the lower edges of
level less than or equal to i,
that's our smaller force.
This is, in some sense, the
hierarchical decomposition
of the forest.
Because there's really
only one forest.
That would make our
lives way easier.
Fun fact, is that that
forest, then, is actually not
just any spanning forest.
It's a minimum spanning
forest, with respect to level.
You've probably heard of
minimum spanning tree.
Minimum spanning forest
is just the analog
for disconnected graphs.
So we're defining the weight
of an edge to be it's level.
And so F log n can't just
be any spanning forest.
It has to prefer
lower-level edges.
Otherwise, this nesting
structure won't be true.
Now, that doesn't uniquely
define the forest or anything.
Because maybe all
the levels are log n.
And then every spanning forest
is a minimum spanning forest.
But it's a constraint
on spanning forest.
Cool Let's go over here.
Let me quickly say how to do an
insert and how to do a query.
These are really easy.
Delete is really
where the action is,
but just to make sure
we're on the same page,
and to introduce a
little bit of notation,
and say a little bit
about what we do.
We are going to store
incidence lists, which
is for every vertex, we
have a list of the incident
edges in a linked list.
So in constant time, we
can add our edge to v
and w's incidence lists.
That's not maintaining any
order or anything special.
Then we also set the level
of the edge to the log n.
That's what I said, every
edge starts at level log n.
And then there's one
more thing, which
is if v and w are
disconnected, and F log n,
we can tell that because we
can do a connectivity query
on F log n.
We have that as an
Euler-tour tree.
So we can see whether v and w
are in different components.
If they are, we
have to merge them.
So we merge them.
We This is what you
call an edge insertion.
So this is an Euler-tour
tree insertion,
that we know how to do in log n.
We reroute and we do a join.
So that's cheap.
And that's it.
So insertion is easy to do
in log n time, actually.
Its deletion that's
going to be painful.
Actually, we're going to
charge through the inserts.
So it'll be end up being
log squared amortized.
But worst case, it's log n.
Great.
I want to say a little
bit about connectivity.
Now we know how to solve
connectivity already.
We do find root on v
and w and in log n time,
we determine whether they're
in the same component.
But I actually claimed--
it's maybe erased by now.
Yeah.
But I claim not to log n query.
I claimed a log
over log log query.
Turns out, that's
really easy to do.
You just change the top
level minimum spanning forest
slightly.
So I want to make F log
n equal to a B-tree.
Or actually, it's
a bunch of B-trees,
one per connected component,
of branching factor log n.
I guess it's a B-tree, so
I have to have some slop.
Theta log n, let's say.
Usually we said with
Euler-tour trees,
it was a balanced
binary search tree.
I'm going to make this
particular forest use a log n
way, B-tree.
This is going to
slow down updates.
But it actually
speeds up queries.
So to do a find root is
now a little bit easier.
Find root should just
be log base log n of n,
which is log n over log log n.
Because find root, you just
need to go to your parent,
to your parent, to your parent.
Go to the top.
And then you have to go
to the leftmost place.
But it's easy, in a
B-tree, to always go
to the leftmost place.
If I had to do a
search within the node,
that would be annoying.
But going to the
leftmost, that's easy.
So I only pay log over
log log for query,
so I got my desired query time.
And I claim the
update is kind of OK.
Because it's slowed down, but
we're already going to pay
log square eventually.
And here we were doing log.
So we don't need
to be that fast.
Update is now going to be--
let's see-- the
height of the tree
times the branching factor.
If we touch nodes in
a root-to-leaf path,
there's log over
log log of them.
For each one, we have to
rewrite the whole node.
So we pay log.
But this is less
than log squared.
So this won't end up hurting us.
Because we only do this
at the top forest level.
We don't do it at
all the levels.
If we did it at
all the levels, we
would lose another log factor,
log over log log factor.
But here, we do this
once at the top,
pay log squared over log log.
Then we have to update log n
other levels, each paying log.
So we're already paying log
squared for the lower level.
So if we increase the top
level a bit, not a big deal.
So that's how you improve
connectivity queries slightly.
And now, finally,
we get to deletes.
This is the moment
you've been waiting for.
How do we do a delete
in this structure?
What are all these
levels good for?
So we're deleting an edge e.
Its endpoints are v and w.
First thing we do is remove
e from the incidence list.
If every edge stores
a pointer to where
it lives in the
incidence list, you
can do that deletion
in constant time.
Great.
So as I said, if e is
not in this forest--
what if it's in a
lower level of forest?
Oh, I see, right.
I forgot.
In variant two, variant two
says the forests are nested.
So if it's in any forest, it's
going to be in the last one.
So if it's not in
the last one, that
means it's not in
any of the forests.
That means we're done.
We do nothing.
That's the easy case.
We didn't destroy
any connectivity,
because the forests represent
maximal connectivity.
They're spanning.
But if it's in the forest,
then something changed.
Then we need to determine,
like in this picture,
is there a replacement edge?
Or is there no replacement edge?
In which case, when there's
no replacement edge,
we basically don't do anything.
We have to do a bunch of
deletes in the forests.
But yeah, is that what
I want to say next?
Yes, we always do that.
We're going to delete e.
We have to delete e.
So we're going to recursively
delete it from f sub e dot
level up to F log n. e
dot level is the earliest
forest it appears in.
And we have to delete
it from all those.
Each of those is an Euler-tour
tree deletion, or cut.
And so each of them pays log
n total cost log squared n.
So this is where the log
squared's coming from.
That's great.
Now we've successfully
deleted the edge.
But now we need to know,
is there a replacement?
And at what level is
there a replacement?
Now, we know by invariant
2, that there could be
no replacement of lower level.
The point is, this is a
minimum spanning tree.
So e was the lowest
level edge that
could connect the two sides,
these two connected components
of the forest.
So if there's any replacements
at e's level or higher,
there might not be a
replacement at e dot level.
But there might be a
replacement at a higher level.
We want to find the smallest
level for which there
is a replacement.
That will preserve
invariant 2, that we
have a minimum spanning forest.
So that's what we're going
to do, loop over the levels
to try to find a
replacement edge.
So we're going to start
at e dot level, loop
potentially up to log
n, call it a level i.
Then I want to identify,
at level i, the two
sides of the edge.
Let Tv and Tw be the trees
of Fi, containing v and w,
respectively.
We just deleted the edge
connecting those two sides.
So we know that they're in two
different trees, Tv and Tw.
And one of them is
smaller than the other.
I'd like to relabel v and
w so that the size of Tv
is less than or equal
to the size of Tw, size,
in terms of number of vertices
from there in the tree.
So swapped v and w if necessary.
Here's the fun thing.
If we apply invariant
1, then we learn
these sizes are not so big.
Claim, at most, 2 to the i.
As you realize it's
almost 2 to the i,
you have to imagine the moment
before this deletion happened,
before we deleted the edge.
Because at that point, Tv and
Tw were actually one tree.
They were connected by edge e.
We've just deleted them.
But the moment before we
deleted them, invariant 1 held.
And so that was a
connected component.
It should have size,
at most, 2 to the i.
Now, we split it.
But that's all we've done.
So the sum of those sizes
has to be at most 2 to the i.
Because that used to be
a connected component.
Cool
So that means that size of Tv
is 1/2 that, at most 2 to i
minus 1.
Because Tv is less
than or equal to Tw.
So it's, at most,
1/2 of the total.
So Tv is even smaller.
In particular, what
that tells us--
now we have Tv and Tw as
kind of separate components
temporarily--
we don't really know that
they're separate at level i.
But we know at level i
minus 1 they are separate.
At level i minus 1, there
is no replacement edge,
by the minimum spanning
forest property.
So what we could
do, at this point,
is take Tv, take all of
the edges internal to Tv,
and push them down
to level i minus 1.
We could afford that.
What do I mean by we
could afford that?
We wouldn't destroy invariant 1.
Because we're taking
2 to the i minus 1
vertices, pushing
all those edges down.
We don't have to
push all of them.
We could push some
subset of the edges down.
Whatever connectivity
component we make at that level
will be of size at
most 2 to d, i minus 1,
and so invariant 1
will be preserved.
So great.
We can afford in
this certain sense of
"afford," to push all of Tv's
edges to level i minus 1.
Great
We don't actually
need to do this.
But what we're going to do
is use it to pay for stuff.
We have this scary
goal, which is
we want to find is there
a replacement edge?
I don't know a good way to
find a replacement edge,
except to do, basically,
a depth first search
and look at all the edges.
That's going to
take a lot of time.
But the good news
is, if we search
from Tv, every edge
that's useless,
we can just decrease its level.
And whenever we decrease
the level of an edge,
we basically get a
free coin to continue.
So you get a free
life every time you
push an edge down by one level.
Because overall,
number of pushes
can be number
insertions times log n.
Because every edge can only
be pushed long n times.
So whenever we push down an
edge, we get a free bonus life,
so we can keep doing our search.
So here's how the search works.
I'm going to say, for each--
this is a little bit
tricky to implement.
I'm going to first tell
you what we want to do
and why that's OK.
And then we'll see
how we actually do it.
So I want to search
from every vertex in Fv.
I want to look at all the
outgoing edges from there
of level i.
Never mind how to
find those edges.
Just pretend you could find
it in constant time per edge.
It's going to be
log n time per edge.
But that's OK.
It's two cases.
Either y is in Tw.
Otherwise, y is
going to be in Tv.
Because we have Tv here.
We have Tw.
We just deleted this edge, e.
Sadly, we want to find
a replacement edge.
So if we look at all the edges
coming out of a vertex in Tv,
this is, I guess, x.
It could be it's an edge
that stays within Tv.
Or could be it's an
edge that goes to Tw.
There are no other options,
because of our invariants.
If it's in Tv, oh,
that's kind of annoying.
Doesn't help us.
But then we can just set
the level of that edge,
e-prime, to be i minus 1.
Because we can afford
to push all of these
edges down by one level.
So that pays for this
round of the loop.
What about the other case?
The other cases
is the good case.
That means we've found a
replacement edge for e.
If we have an edge
from Tv to Tw.
And at level i, we did
these levels in order.
Did I say that?
Yeah, we're doing
levels in order.
So if we can find this is the
lowest level replacement edge,
so we do it.
We insert that edge into
Fi using an Euler-tour tree
insertion.
And then we're done.
So we stop the algorithm.
The moment we find a
desired edge we're happy.
Now, maybe there
are lots of edges.
So we've got to stop when
we find the first one.
Then we've restored our minimum
spanning forest property.
We have maximal connectivity,
all these great things.
As long as we
don't find an edge,
we can push things down a
level and pay for this round.
So it's constant time or log
n time to do the last step.
But all the other steps are paid
for by the decrease in level.
So the claim is overall,
we pay log squared n.
Because we had to do log
squared n for these deletions.
Plus log n times the
number of level decreases.
That's for this step.
I claim that each round
of this loop cost log n.
So that's why we've
get log n times
number of level decreases.
But number of level
decreases is, at most,
number of edge
insertions times log n.
Because each edge can
only decrease in level
log n times, by
definition of levels.
And so we can charge to
the insert operations
at a factor of log n.
So there's two log n's here.
So inserts now cost log
squared amortized as well.
To deletes costs log
squared amortized.
And we get log squared overall.
One last issue though, which
is how do we do this step?
Actually, there's another
step that's not so trivial,
this one.
We need to know the size
of Tv and the size of Tw.
Well, that's easy.
I just store subtree
sizes at every node.
So then I look at
the root of the BST,
and it tells me how
big that tree is.
And so I can see which is
bigger and switch accordingly.
But that's trivial.
This one requires a
different augmentation
for Euler-tour trees.
And again, in both
of these situations,
we're using the fact that we
can augment on subtrees, not
on paths.
That's why we need Euler-tour
trees, not link cut trees.
So what we store in F--
why did I write Fv?
I mean Tv here.
So in Fi-- this is for each i,
but at the forest at level i--
what I'm going to store is at
every node in the Euler-tour
tree, I want to know in the
subtree rooted in that node--
so here's Euler-tour tree.
Here's a node, v.
This is a tree in Fi.
I want to know, in
this subtree, in here,
is there any node that has a
level i edge incident to it?
So I want to know, are
there any level i edges?
If there aren't any
level i edges, then
for the purposes
of this search, I
should just skip that subtree.
It's as if the
subtree was erased.
So I have some tree.
It has height log n overall.
I erase some of the
subtrees according
to this bit, which is an
easy thing to keep track of.
It's an augmentation,
constant factor overhead.
Then I basically want to
do an in-order traversal
of this tree, but
skipping the stuff below.
So I mean, one way to think of
it is you just repeatedly call
successor, like successor
in a binary search tree.
But whenever I see that there's
no level edges below me,
I just skip.
So in log n time you can
basically find the next place
where there's an outgoing edge.
I guess also, the
incidence lists
have to be stored
separately for each level.
So you can say, what are
your outgoing level i
edges from a vertex?
This lets you find
the vertex quickly,
but then you have to
find the edges quickly.
So the instance lists are not
just stored as one single link
lists, one link list per level.
But that's easy to do.
So then from this, vertex we
can find all the outgoing level
i edges.
And we can do this
4 loop efficiently.
And whenever it's
low, we get to charge.
In the remaining
negative two minutes,
let me tell you briefly
about other problems that
have been solved.
So this finishes log squared
n fully dynamic connectivity.
I wasn't planning to spend
much time on this anyway.
There are notes.
If you're interested in
the specific problems,
I'll just tell you
what the problems are.
Generalization of connectivity
is k connectivity.
I don't just want to know, is
there one path from v to w?
I want to know are there k
disjoint paths from v to w?
So they could be edge-disjoint
or vertex-disjoint paths,
might be your goal.
In that case, poly
log solutions are
known for 2 connectivity
edge or vertex.
This is the result, actually,
I used in my very first graph
algorithms papers, where I first
learned about dynamic graphs.
In log to the fourth n time,
you can maintain 2 edge
connectivity.
It's open for k equals
3, even, whether you
can achieve that bound.
So kind of lame.
Another problem is
minimum spanning forest.
So you don't just want to
maintain some spanning forest.
Maybe you actually have
weights on the edges
and you want the
minimum spanning for us.
That it turns out, you can
solve with a couple extra log
factors.
So in log to the fourth
n time, with an extra log
squared factor, you can
reduce to the problem
of dynamic connectivity.
And so log to the
forth overall, you
can maintain minimum
spanning forest.
Another problem is
planarity testing.
You want to insert or delete
edges and, at all points,
know whether your
graph is planar.
And that, there's no great
results known for that.
It's like n to the 2/3.
Directed graphs,
things get really hard.
There are two problems
I've surveyed here.
There's probably more.
But the most
fundamental questions
are the analog of
connectivity is
what I call dynamic
transitive closure, which
means given two vertices,
v and w, I want to know,
is there a directed path from
v to w instead of undirected?
At the moment, a
bunch of results
match a trade-off curve
which should be update times
query is roughly m times n, a
number of edges times number
of vertices.
This is big.
But there are a bunch of results
that achieve this trade-off.
I don't think I'm
matching lower bound.
But it's also open, whether
this entire trade-off
curve could be achieved.
There's various points on
the curve where you pay
square root of n for an update.
Then you pay like,
m times square root
of n for the query or vice
versa, stuff like that.
And then a harder
version of this
is you have weights
on the edges.
And now the query is
not just find a path,
find the shortest path.
This is what I call dynamic
all pairs shortest paths.
This is even harder.
There are some results where you
can do like, roughly, n squared
time updates constant query.
So it's maybe similar
type of trade-off curves,
not really known.
When all the weights
of the edges are 1,
you just want to find the
shortest path in terms
of the number of edges, you can
do not really that much better.
Still, this is the product.
But at least more of the
trade curve has been solved.
So that's a quick overview of
dynamic graphs, more generally.
Dynamic graphs come up all
over the place, obviously.
You have network where the
links are changing, or Facebook,
you want to maintain
connections but people friend
and de-friend all the time.
So you want to maintain whatever
structure you care about.
Anyway, that's dynamic
graphs upper bounds.
Next class will be
lower bounds, the log n.